my name is Roger Cornell I'm Explosives
engineer
Oh God I would walk away in movies
without FLETC when it explodes behind
man there's no one okay so as soon as
this clip starts a couple really
pressing issues that you should be
focusing on the first is that if you
have grenades and other weapons you
shouldn't be carrying them around inside
a guitar case on top of that as soon as
he pulls the grenades out you'll notice
that he pulls out not one but two of
those pins with his teeth I've tried it
a few times and you really have to put
all of your strength to get that thing
dislodged so pulling any kind of grenade
pin out with your mouth unless it's been
tampered with beforehand is just
completely unrealistic the most common
misconceptions I'm aware of one is that
any explosive device when it goes off
we'll throw a human being into the air
the detonation itself and the pressure
wave they're gonna do plenty of damage
to the human body propelling you into
the air isn't going to be one of the
things that you experience so being
thrown is not really is not really a
thing
[Music]
you'll also see that just from those two
grenades you have this gigantic fireball
grenades especially a military grenade
is going to be composed of what's called
secondary explosives and these secondary
explosives go through detonation
processes a detonation process is
extremely rapid and it's certainly not
going to be this prolonged explosion
that you see here when you see a
gigantic fireball and you see just
flames everywhere and you can usually
assume that they're exaggerating quite a
bit I mean it's not that surprising it's
a Quentin Tarantino movie so I really
wouldn't expect anything less
the only explosive device you see in
that clip is what seems to be one pack
of dynamite
dynamites used specifically for blasting
operations so even though it's made for
situations like this if you have just
one bundle in the corner of a house you
will never get any kind of an explosion
on this order you might have a chunk of
the house missing right where that
explosive charge was but that's about it
the house would probably still be
standing unless there were a lot of
other charges placed throughout the
house that were unaware of certainly not
every piece of the building would be in
flames
it looks like he's in a dummy town once
he hears sirens he realizes that he's
about to be in the middle of a nuclear
test the refrigerators lead-lined and
the reason this is important is that
lead can actually block certain types of
radiation so that's the premise is that
all the lead in this fridge is going to
block the radiation and somehow protect
Indiana Jones some of the things that
are picking are somewhat accurate I mean
a nuclear detonation or a nuclear event
would produce all kinds of light and
it's amazingly destructive so they're
showing the force of it correctly just
not how it's going to impact the fridge
which is the main issue with the scene
sure the lead lining is going to protect
a little bit from some of the radiation
although it's not nearly enough to
prevent all of the radiation from
affecting you there's no way you can
survive an impact like that the fact
that he gets out immediately and he'll
actually walk up to look at the the the
aftermath of the mushroom cloud from the
nuclear event there's a ton of nuclear
fallout when you have these events and
you want to be as far away from this as
possible because the radiation that it
produces it sticks around for quite a
while and the fact that he lives on in
the movie and doesn't die in a couple
hours from radiation sickness is just
completely ridiculous
right off the bat it's Michael Bay
it's transformers movie you have
Decepticons running around so how real
can you expect it to be when you see the
fighter jets in action and you'll notice
these bursts of light coming off the
bottom if I to guess what that was that
would probably be flares and a lot of
times their use of the planes can avoid
heat-seeking missiles they're a source
of heat that can distract the missile
from continuing to fly towards the jet
now whether or not Decepticons
use heat-seeking missiles I have no idea
so during this initial explosion what
I'm assuming they're doing is
essentially marking their target if
you're gonna drop munitions that don't
have any kind of propulsion or guidance
but you want to be very very sure where
you're going to drop those those bombs
you see shia labeouf get just almost
catapulted into the air it almost
actually looks like he's stepping on
like a trampoline I can't see any reason
why he would be tumbling in the air like
that
the pressure wave that's radiating you
know it is moving outward away from the
explosion so if you were to be thrown at
all you might be thrown backwards and
fall to the ground but setting it all
aside there's at least realistic
situations some of the things that the
aircraft did that progression from
marking your target and then dropping
the energetic load on top of it my guess
is that he was probably consulted as to
how the how the Department of Defense
would actually go through their
procedures
he takes essentially his claws and he
strikes them against the rocks to create
a spark to initiate the flame if I'm
remembering correctly it's adamantium
what his claws are made of which is
completely fictitious I have no idea
what the properties of that material
would be but there are a lot of metals
out there that don't spark there are
other ways to initiate fuel that seems
like a pretty silly one that probably
wouldn't work out you know that's a very
rocky surface even if you got to start
burning it would probably die out before
it ever reach the helicopter I would
never expect this to explode you have a
helicopter that's crashed and that's
already leaking fuel so when the fuel
tank ruptures there's no pressure vessel
that can heat up that can allow pressure
to build where you'd actually get some
sort of an explosion but if you had an
explosion on that scale you'd have
pieces of that helicopter being thrown
in every direction not to mention the
pressure wave that's produced so he
would he would definitely hit the ground
at some point he regenerates so I guess
you can walk away from this he'd be fine
[Music]
you see some grenade being launched at
Hancock and he somehow to flex it into a
car if we just accept the fact that he
can't be hurt and then he can just
deflect bullets and that's fine they're
still really big issues with this scene
the effect of the grenade is unrealistic
the way it initiates is incorrect using
the police car as you know a way of
stopping bullets is just ill-advised
cars don't stop bullets cars can deflect
bullets cars have a lot of weak points
so you wouldn't want to ever use it as a
shield not expect the doors to have
bulletproof inserts but that's about it
the roof of the car and the floor of the
car are probably pretty thin those are
going to be the most vulnerable parts of
that vehicle the way he's holding it is
probably the least safe way that you
could be using that car for protection
to create an explosion that massive you
would need more explosive material than
you could carry with you and you need to
plant it everywhere it would take just
unlimited financial resources a huge
amount of time to place the charges
where you need to put them they try to
add in some cool sound effects it's not
gonna sound anything like that the
actual audio event is very rapid it's
very loud and it's more of a crack they
try to show the shock actually moving
outward essentially past Denzel you can
see the grass start to move forward and
then retract back there you see a little
that was a shock wave moving past so
seeing that sort of motion within the
grass in that scene could actually be
realistic if you're that close where you
can see the shock around you it's gonna
at least hurt because you have this
sudden change in pressure and pressure
that's gonna feel like someone's at the
very least just punching you as hard as
they can
you're not just gonna keep walking all
sorts of metals being thrown there's
fragmentation everywhere
[Music]
this is one of my favorite movies so I
really hate laying into it like I'm
about to but so he essentially rigged
this hospital with explosives he's
setting them off wirelessly and then
he's just watching as the demolition
unfolds you could have you know
explosions going off at different times
in different locations so that's
actually not unreasonable what is
unreasonable is to pull that off would
be expensive and you'd also need to
somehow you know go through a hospital
and place all these charges without
anybody noticing I'm not entirely sure
that he would have the resources the
time and be able to disguise everything
to actually pull something like this off
especially you know given what the Joker
is wearing there's no way he would go
through this entire process without
being seen by somebody
the funny thing is this e is one of the
most realistic scenes we're probably
gonna see there is one resounding issue
with this scene though all those
pressurized tanks the fact that all
these things are ruptured and just
sitting there it's weird that would
never happen explode this I think is
actually the most accurate scene so you
have a fuel tank that was just riddled
with bullet holes so it has no way of
accelerating the reaction I don't know
why chickens would explode there they're
fecal matter could probably combust the
wooden cages could light on fire but why
you'd get an explosion I have no idea I
think the scenes kind of intending to be
a bit ridiculous and it definitely is
the flames unrealistic but the way
they're pushed back is actually somewhat
believable so you know the fact that
they aren't cut up and that they're not
bleeding profusely the fragmentation in
that situation would be much more deadly
the way he's complaining is unrealistic
but the fact that he's complaining about
his ears is actually realistic you know
when you have blast overpressure there
are certain parts of the human body that
are susceptible they're very susceptible
to shifts and pressure your eardrums are
one and your lungs are another an
extreme case is if the pressure was
strong enough you could rupture your
lungs and if that happens or if anything
near that happens he's not gonna be
talking he's gonna be laying there
gasping for whatever breath he can pull
in so he seems to be in much better
shape than I would imagine him to be if
you got hit with a pressure wave you're
probably be concussed as well so an MRI
might not be a bad idea oh my god I walk
away in movies without [ __ ] with
explosive er then there's no way a cop
on that